[THEME MUSIC]
JESSICA: Hi, I'm
Jessica, and today, I'm
going to be talking about
a chemical demonstration I
like to call, "Money to Burn."
And chemist Dr.
Bassam Shakhashiri--
here he is-- is actually going
to be showing us the demo.
He's the president of the
American Chemical Society,
and is performing this
demo right here at MIT.
Let's see if he has
some money to burn.
DR. BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
What I am going to do
now is going to reach in here.
I'm going to take
dollar bill, and I'm
going to put it in the
flame just like that.
[AWED GASPS]
STUDENT: Whoa!
DR. BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Was that too fast?
What we always do in science
is repeat the experiment,
so I take out what looks
like a dollar bill,
but it's not a real dollar bill.
I bring it close to the flame.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
DR. BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Disappears into thin air.
It looks like magic, right?
I love magic.
Magic is engaging,
but not informative.
JESSICA: How is that dollar
bill burning up so quickly?
Well, it's actually
not a dollar bill.
It's called flash
paper, and it's
paper that has been treated
with chemicals to make it burn
quickly and leave no ashes.
Now, flash paper
has been nitrated.
Practically, what that means
is that you soak the paper
in a mixture of concentrated
nitric and sulfuric acids.
The cellulose in the
paper then reacts
with the acid to produce
nitrated cellulose and water.
The reaction is this.
So our nitric acid here
mixes with the cellulose.
Now, this is actually
just one unit
in the big polymer
that is cellulose.
It's got lots of little units
of C6H10O5, so in this equation,
I'm only writing one unit.
And that's creating nitrated
cellulose and water.
Now, the nitro group, the
NO2 is the reactive group,
and it can be very
reactive depending
on the molecule that it's in.
You've no doubt heard
of nitroglycerin,
which looks like this.
It's an explosive liquid.
Or TNT, which actually
stands for trinitrotoluene.
It looks like this.
So all of these molecules
have nitro groups in them,
and it's the nitro,
or NO2, groups that
make these molecules explosive.
Now, let's watch what happens
when Dr. Shakhashiri tries
this again, but this time,
with a real dollar bill.
DR. BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
I'd like someone
in the audience to let me
borrow from them a real $1 bill.
Is there someone
in the audience who
would let me--
who would trust me
with a real $1
bill or a $5 bill?
Steve, how about
a $20 bill, huh?
You got a $20 bill?
OK, here's $1 bill.
It's a real $1 bill.
You know what I'm going
to do with it, don't you?
So I have a jar right here,
and I have, in this jar--
what do you suppose--
what does this look like?
I have a liquid.
What does it look like?
Looks like?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
DR. BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Looks like water.
The way we describe this
liquid is to say it's
a clear and colorless liquid,
which is what water is.
So I'm going to take
this liquid, and--
so I want everybody to
see the jar right here.
Get this out of the way.
I'm going to take
the dollar bill.
I'm going to soak it in this
clear and colorless liquid,
which looks like water,
and I'm going to fish it
out using those tongs.
You see, it's dripping
like any wet object would.
And then I'm going to
take it to the flame.
Take a good look at
it, now, [? Judy. ?]
It may be the last
time you see it.
So here is the
dollar bill on fire.
Or is it?
[AWED GASPS]
DR. BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: But you
did see a flame, didn't you?
STUDENT: Yes!
DR. BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
So now, I ask you,
can this liquid be water?
STUDENT: No!
DR. BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
You know from experience
that water does not burn
under these conditions.
Right?
So I will tell you
what's in this jar.
This clear and
colorless liquid is
a mixture of rubbing alcohol
and water, isopropyl alcohol
and water.
You know also from experience
that when you burn alcohol,
what color flame do you see?
It's kind of bluish.
You remember what color
flame you saw here?
It was a little yellowish.
Right?
That's because we also added a
little bit of sodium chloride
in there.
The eye is more sensitive
to the yellow color
than it is to the blue color,
so we added the sodium chloride
to enhance the visibility
of what's going on.
JESSICA: All right, so
what happened there?
Dr. Shakhashiri soaked the
money in a solution of water,
rubbing alcohol, and a
little bit of table salt.
When he puts the money in
the flame, the alcohol burns,
producing heat and light,
energy, and carbon dioxide
and water.
The reaction is this.
There's our alcohol
reacting with oxygen,
producing carbon dioxide,
water, and energy.
So why doesn't the bill burn?
If you have a beaker of
alcohol and light it on fire,
it's just that very
top layer of alcohol
and the gas above it that burns.
The rest of the alcohol
in the beaker does not.
So that's what's happening
with our dollar bill.
Let's draw a dollar
bill right here.
So the alcohol, ROH
could be any alcohol,
is evaporating off the
bill, turning into a gas,
and burning, so those are
the flames that you see.
But remember that the
solution is 50% water.
The water is evaporating much
less quickly than the alcohol,
staying in the bill and
preventing the paper
from burning.
So that's one way to
hold onto your cash.
Hope you enjoyed
"Money to Burn,"
and I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]